[음악]
그 사람입니다 제가 오늘도
연남동 리모델링 현장에 좀 와 있는데
저 일단 설계하신 김준석 소장님
모셨습니다
안녕하세요이 건물은 어떻게 좀
디자인했는지 기존에 다세대주택으로
사용되던 건물이었고요
근린생활시설로 용도변경을 하면서
용적률이 부족한 부분이 있었는데
추가로 수평 및 수식증축을 통해서
최대 용적률을 확보할 수 있도록
그렇게 리모델링한 케이스예요 지금
보시는 건물은 지하가 없었던
건물이고요
리모델링이기 때문에
지하를 새로 만들 수는 없죠 그래서
지상에 있는 면적만 활용한 그런
사례라고 보시면 될 것 같아요 보통
주택에서 상가로 리모델링할 때
용도변경이라는 과정을 거쳐야 되는데
용도변경을 할 때 요즘 이슈가 되는
사항들이
방화창 그리고 뭐 차면시설 내부
싱크대 철거 그리고 주차될수
[음악]
재미있게 했고 사실 이게 면적이
그렇게 크진 않아요 되게 작은
땅인데
커튼월로 해서 좀 되게 커보이는 그런
느낌이 나고 그리고 이제 위에는
그래서 건물이 좀 커 보일 수 있게네
연장을 했고 이쪽은
롱브릭
타일로 사용한 거 같고 그리고 여기
뒤쪽으로 보니까
기존 걸 살려 놨네요
기존 벽돌 위에다가 페인트 도장만
새로 했습니다
그래서 어떻게 보면 딱 그 보여지는
부분만
힘을 많이 주고 안 보이는 부분은 뭐
기존 거를 좀 살려 넣는 그런
리모델링이 저는 되게 괜찮은
리모델링이라 생각을 합니다
본격적으로 좀 안에 들어가서 좀
보도록 하시죠네 건물 맨 꼭대기
4층에 좀 올라왔는데 일단은 가장
눈에 띄는 거는
베란다 공간이 굉장히 크더라고요
진짜 엄청 큰데 이게 이제 3층에
지붕이죠
지붕에 일부 공간은 이제 활용하다
보니까 저희가 3층이 이제 면적이 한
몇 평 정도 되는데
4층에서 증축한 면적은 10평 정도
밖에 안 돼요 그래서 나머지 14평의
공간이 외부 공간으로 확보가 되어
있는 거죠 그래서 여러분들이 아마
모르시는
부분 중에 하나가
베란다
발코니 테라스 이거를
구분을 잘 못하시거든요 저희도 사실
용어를 막 혼재해서 많이 사용을
하는데
정식적으로 이제
명칭에 대한 정의를 설명을 드리면
이렇게 이제 하부층의 지붕을
활용하는게
베란다 그 다음에 1층에서 건물하고
연결되어 있는 외부 공간이 테라스
각층에서
별도의 구조물을 뽑아내서 만들어
주는게
발코니 발코니는 예전에 그 로미오와
줄리엣이 있던
곳 있잖아요 거기가 이제 발코니라고
보시면 될 것 같고 또 많은 분들이
착각하시는게 아파트에 있는 나와 있는
부분을 다 베란다라고
얘기하시죠 베란다가 아니에요
발코니입니다 그래서 건축 앞으로도 그
부분을 이제 서비스 발코니라고 해요
면적에 포함되지 않은 외부공간 그래서
서비스 발코니 같은 경우에는 주거일
경우에는 확장이 합법적인데 그 외의
시설에서는 확장해서 사용하면 안 되고
외부 공간으로 사용을 하셔야 돼요
그러니까 그래서 주택을
근생으로 바꿀 때 그런 발코니 공간은
다 없애야 돼요 다 철거해야 되기
때문에요 부분을 조금 여러분들
기억하시면 좋을 것 같습니다요 창에
대해서도 좀 설명드릴게 좀 있어요
그 열리는 창을 개폐창이라고 하는데
창호에도 종류들이 있어요 그래서 지금
저희 설치된 창호 같은 경우에는
이렇게
여닫이 방식으로 열리는 창호고이 창을
케이스먼트 창이라고 합니다 그리고
아래쪽에서
밀어서 여는 창을 프로젝트 창이라고
하고 위에서부터 당겨서 안쪽으로 여는
창을 틸트 창이라 그래요 틸트하고 안
여닫이가 안쪽으로 열리는 창이 같이
돼 있는 걸 터낸테이트 어려운데요
이렇게 창문들에 대한 종류들이 있고요
각각의 특징을 좀 말씀드리자면
케이스먼트 같은 경우가 창이 90도로
개폐가 가능해서
환기 면적을 가장 많이 확보를 할 수
있어요
근데 또 창이 너무 크면 열었을 때
불안하거나 위험할 수가 있으니까이
안쪽에 보시는게 각도 조절 장치에요
그래서 이거를 통해서 창이 얼만큼
열리는지를 조절할 수가 있어요 그
밑으로 열리는 건 좀 고층 빌딩에서
많이 판단해가지고 위험하기 때문에
사실 열리는 개폐 면적이 크지 않은
창들을 설치를 하고
프로젝트 창 같은 경우에는 비 오는
날에도 환기를 시킬 수가 있어서 아
그렇구나 여기
4층은 지금 10평 증축한 부분이랑
이렇게 발코니 공간을 넓게
빼가지고 좀 임대하기 너무 좋을 것
같아요 그리고 4층 같은 경우에는
새롭게 증축을 했기 때문에
천장 높이가 다른 층에 비해서는 조금
더 높아요
2008m 정도 되는데
단열재를 또 천장 위로 설치를 해서
내부에서 천장 보라고 하죠
천장 높이를 좀 최대한 확보를
했습니다 그리고요 느낌이 되게 괜찮은
거 같아요요
타일도 잘 고르셨네요네 건축주님께서
이제 선택하신 파일인데 이번 테라조
무늬의 타일이 또
맞아요
많이들 적용하고 계시죠
3층 같은 경우에는 기존에 여기가
최상층이었어요 그래서
단열재가 붙어 있었기 때문에 그거를
굳이 다 철거하진 않았고 그 대신에
이제 별도로 천장 마감을 해서
등은 지금 다 매립형태로
적용이 됐어요
괜찮네 뭔가 약간 되게 깔끔해졌는데
사실 이제
인테리어적인 요소들이에요 저희가
건축공사를 하면서 이렇게까지 마감을
하는 케이스가 많지는 않아요 원하시면
이런 정도의 마감은 충분히 건축
공사에서도 해드릴 수가 있습니다 저도
이제 수많은 현장들 아침에 이렇게
매립하는 경우는 또 몇 번 안 본 거
같은데
근데 되게 깔끔하고 괜찮은데 저희가
항상 좀 큰 거도 났고 그런 건물들이
많았었기 때문에 노출로 해서 좀
개방감 있게 확보를 하려고 했었는데
좀 부득이하게 이제 그렇게 적용된
사례긴 해요 근데 지금 보시면은
천장도 그렇고 벽도 미장하고서 페인트
마감을 바닥도 지금 이제
몰탈 마감까지 해 놓은 상태라서요
정도 상태라면
임차 맞추기에는 충분할 것 같습니다
내부의 기둥이 없잖아요
기존에 이제 다세대주택으로 사용할 때
내부 구획되는 벽들이 다
조적벽이었습니다 대신에
변경하면서
기존의 창호랑 벽으로 돼 있던
구간들을 철거를 하고 커튼으로
설치하게 되니까 그 부분에 대한
구조 보강이 좀 들어갔어 보통 이제
주택 건물들은 다 조적이 대부분이어서
그거 보강하는데 비용이 많이 들거든요
이거는 이미 돼 있어서 철근콘크리트로
돼 있어서 그나마 좀 리모델링 비용을
좀 세이브 하지 않았나 한층에 이제
폭이 6m 정도 밖에 안 돼서 이게
만약에 넓었으면 또 가운데 기둥
보강이 됐었어야 될 거예요
근데이 폭도 이제 최근 콘크리트
구조로 이제 받쳐주기에 좀 적합한
폭이라서 그렇게 진행을 하게 됐습니다
전면으로는 아까 외부에서 보셨던
알겠습니다네 그리고 여기 2층으로
왔는데
확실히
매립이 깔끔하네요 3층하고 또 느낌이
다르죠 만약에 친구만 좀 높다라고
하면은
매립으로 하는 것도 되게 생각해 볼
필요가 있는 것 같아요
천장 마감을 어쨌든 하게 되면
보합으로
시공을 해줘야 되기 때문에 그만큼의
높이가 감소할 수밖에 없습니다 같은
층고지만 3층에 비해서는 그래도
2층이 그만큼의 높이는 더 확보를
했고요 대신에 3층은 매립조명으로
들어갔던 대신에 2층은 이제
레이스웨이라는 철물을 달고 여기에
이제
LED 바 조명을
시공할 예정이에요 아 그리고 여기가
여기에 이제 발코니입니다 여러분 아까
위에서 봤던 거는 베란다 그리고
여기에
발코니입니다 이렇게 외부에 돌출된
기존의 이제
확보가 돼 있었던
공간이고요이 부분은 이제
난간 설치를 할 거고 바닥에는 이제
타일 마감으로 이렇게 조성을 해 줄
예정이에요이 공간도 괜찮네요이 정도면
야간에도 하실 수 있게 지금
벽 쪽에는 벽 등에도
약간 여기
등 불 나오면 되게 은은할 것
같아요네 마지막 1층에 와 있는데
원래 여기가 주차장이었죠 여기가
주차장으로 사용되던 공간이었는데
저희가 용도 변경하고 이렇게
리모델링하면서이 주차장 공간을
근린생활시설 면적에 포함을 시켰습니다
여기 이제 화장실 구분돼요
1층도 이제 이쪽 면으로 다 창을
계획을 했는데
다른 층은 다 바닥까지 좀 내려오는
창으로 적용했었는데 1층 같은
경우에는
옆쪽에 있는 주차 공간하고
레벨 차이가 좀 있어요 그래서 창이
아래까지 내렸을 경우에는 누수가 될
수도 있고 그 창 합으로 이제
옆면이 노출이 되니까 미관상 좋지
않아서 좀 화창 하부 턱을 계획을
해줬습니다
진짜 잘한 거 같아요 이게 사실
준공된 것만 보면은 창을 이상하게
해서 거기 비가 많이 새더라고요
약간 이런게 좀 어떻게 보면 저희가
하면서
생긴 거잖아요 그렇죠 이렇게
창을내는 부분도 되게 좀 신경 쓸
필요가 있습니다 여기서 진짜 비 새는
걸 좀 너무 많이 봐서 제가
봤을 때는 규모가 크진 않지만 좀
알아야 될 포인트들이 좀 많이 있어요
주택으로 어찌됐든 근생으로 바꿀 때는
주차될 수가 이제 더 줄 어드니까
이렇게 좀
증축을 수평 중축을 할 수 있다라는
거를 좀 알고 계시면 좋을 거 같고
오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요 다음
시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다